welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz and I am
joined today it's another late night
session in the hunted offices so thank
you thank you for joining me this
evening but I'm joined by Callum Lyle
who is a director at Robertson some
recruitment agency that's me that's me I
just practiced that about freezing I
know it's a bit late so thanks for
joining me mate and Butler as I was
saying before we went live where I
always also took a cheeky look for your
Linkedin yeah but how did you get into
recruitment Canon so I I think I think
probably like most people you just fall
into an agreement I'm not sure many
people would just jump out the room
wanting to speck CDs kind of just fell
in fell into recruitment I graduated
from Bournemouth uni international
hospitality management so interested
it'll be quite an unusual unusual degree
or a degree what made you pick that my
own man actually so I think before you
need you don't really know what you want
to do and kind of like leaving uni don't
really know what you want to do so my
lad from Glasgow proper proper
Glaswegian grafter yeah he so he did
hospitality management in Strathclyde
uni which is like a second uni in
Glasgow okay and worked his way up the
corporate ladder so actually started
with stakus who got bought by Hilton but
then got into HR that's actually one of
my drivers for wanting to get into
recruitment so I did my dissertation I
just became interested in like it really
he was taught people direct to hate to
our director of lots of big lots of big
business is influenced by a dad they're
influenced by my dad got really
interested in employee engagement and
one people why people work somewhere or
why a lot of people why the people Sony
people hate their job exactly exactly
sort of how some business is absolutely
smash it and yeah that is interesting to
be fair yeah so I got really interested
in in that and then
I think just like like all these things
yeah you leave you leave uni and you
type in to be honest recruitments
everywhere is yeah area you type in any
job you could type in bloody zookeeper
awesome yeah and recruitment would still
be the number at first obviously when
you do that you don't realize this
actually that's a recruiting that it's
trying to did you get 100 mom applied
for all these jobs today and really you
gave your CV it's a lot job that no long
as this may I also found that just
application process and just applying
for jobs really interesting I I don't
think I've ever got a job in like a
conventional yeah type way I got my I
did a placement as part of Union I sort
of tell this story of now I got that via
reading an article in a paper which was
via the VP and Vince continental hotel
groups um and it was effectively
millennial bashing likely and this was
2012 so probably quite early for people
to really jump on that bandwagon ESA was
lazy and all this good and I wrote him a
letter so I wrote him a letter and said
yeah I know really old school saying hey
I think I'm you went to type then I kind
of saying I I can partly agree with you
but I'm actually I'd like to prove you
wrong
yeah this and not expectancy or feedback
I sent it to the states and the PA next
week go back to me and offer me a job
okay that's my internship so I just I
enjoyed the saw chase of getting getting
through to some of these these people
and obviously I've always lived a fairly
comfortable and ridiculously lucky
lifestyle so you sort of become you
become accustomed to having nice things
were going a nice holidays but I don't
want to sponge it all off my parents so
recruitment every recruitment job says
you're gonna runner yeah so that
attracted you go in for Rolexes in the
face good stylist
so then so then just to set the scene
and so then you go into recruitment and
then you've worked at Robertson summer
for just over five years so just and
that's been your only recruitment drive
only McCrimmon job yeah interesting so I
guess before you joined them what so by
this point was your perception of
recruitment like was you was you then
actively interviewing A to B interview
if I'm honest I I applied for a couple
of things I went to one of these like a
preto Norris Clarence House that I hated
it had a story I think the yeah I had a
chap called Jack Pryor on and he went
through that and it sounded grim me I
never did any of that it's just it's a
competition series who shouts the
loudest and that's not really why I
wanted to people get shot there and then
then like yeah so and to be honest I got
I got through it those 40 grads or
wherever you were it was the worst thing
you have to do for that process um
there's a whole host of different tasks
and stuff yeah but what one quite good
one actually is selling selling someone
else yeah that's that's what he said he
said that's what you enjoyed the most
okay yes so that's quite good why is
that that's interesting you said that as
well why did why is that good because it
actually allows you to sort of assesses
your qualification
skills and I think that's a good
resource is a really good listener and
actually sort of takes takes the
information they're given you and
portrays it in a you didn't have to sell
Penman so I didn't have that was that
was the the only recruitment into you I
went to and I kind of left that thinking
I don't really want to be one of these
people so yeah because that's what I
mean did that that's the interesting
thing because like that the sort of same
experience
Jack had it like I actually got per more
equipment do you know I mean yeah that's
interested in like I wasn't quite put
off I was like I just didn't think that
was the person that I wanted to be yeah
and I've the perception of recruitment
before going in was money everyone's
[ __ ] really well yeah people was
down there with a state agency isn't it
big in terms of just the stereotype of
going into recruitment or I'm a
recruiter yeah
I've always been really proud of being a
creature and I think every good
recruiter I know is proud is proud of
being a recruiter and I saw it as a big
opportunity because actually if the
expectations down down interest very low
even if you're mediocre you're sort of
no no that's pretty interesting so then
how does sir then how did he end up with
Roberts and some of them so I I saw I
was going it's probably April time
graduating in June I saw an application
or I saw a read advert for a recruitment
business in Gerald's cross which was ten
minutes down the road from my family
family house and I didn't apply but I
sort of saw that advert I thought there
can't be that many recruitment in since
Gerald's cross so I googled recruitment
Charles cross Robert Sumner was the only
company that came up so I found them I
found marks who's the owners details via
the website so just email and the advert
was actually sort of advertising another
assessment day and I thought it was on a
Saturday mmm and I remember was doing by
I had plans on the Saturday so instead
of applying I emailed mark and said
listen I can't I can't come on Saturday
however I'm just down the road and I
think I'm probably the sort of person
that you're gonna say you Roman down the
road and pace of it actually posted your
arts cross see you went direct direct
yes fair enough well it's a good when I
actually said it was quite a good lesson
in hindsight because mark was obviously
the sort of person that I'd be trying to
contact as a as ourselves yeah Roberts
under a sales
recruiter but he's he's a sort of Sales
Director or owner of her head of a sale
was type business and I wrote him this
long email and he came back and said
profile looks good can see you 10 a.m.
tomorrow so that was it so it's kind of
mmm it's a good lesson of these guys
don't want to read the watch they they
they just want straights video and
that's really interesting so yeah went
down next day at 10 a.m. come in like me
go ask me to go back later that day to a
presentation on the same day same day
nice mate and then you've been there
five years five years we love that so
let's just just set the sort of van the
sort of course of your Korean and we'll
break it down right so right now your
and the director of one of the obviously
the director with mark of the business
right so the typical obviously people
recruit to get it sold all the time you
could join here and your bit training
and then become a manager that's all
that so you've done that typical sort of
journey right yeah so so you start as a
consultant how long do you do that for
just only just over a year okay and
after that what did you do to do those I
went into like senior senior consultant
for then started taking some sort of
managerial abilities so kind of billing
billing manager civilian manager for how
long roughly about a year and a half
yeah and then after that and then
actually swapped roles with mark really
so it was a big step for him yeah what
roles in mark and look how it looked
after the whole team okay so and then
how long have you looked after the whole
team for that just coming up to three
years three or so so okay so like two
and a bit years like billing that are
there and then how long have you not
build for three years yes really
okay so let's break that down then say
where why always light so actually so
what set to do recruiting or what's it's
a beauty
well IIT sells just know I only ever
recruited in the IT salesman oh cool and
the business is 19 years old so until
two years ago we'd never done anything
bar I t-cells okay so real business
added legit reputation been doing it for
all ages obviously yeah okay that's
really interesting now we do tech as
well yeah call perfect three consults
but for you yeah I've been to I to
sounds okay amazing so firstly like how
are your first one mum saying and
telling performance watch my first 12
months three months really didn't like
it really why the nanaka because because
I'd come from like a hospitality
background and I done sales in
hospitality I think it was a big move
for me and quite a lot of people were
saying it might not be the right move
and I was really focused on I had offers
at like 30 K or whatever and often see I
took eighteen much much less to go into
to go into recruitment so I went in
really motivated to stand money because
that's yeah that was one of the main
purposes of me doing it I
you kind of and I kind of got involved
in like those of certain office politics
or my team leader left on my second
month actually first month really
back-end to start the second month and I
kind of 50% focused on recruitment and
50% focused on money politics okay
the other type stuff and I saw the bad
more than I saw the good and people
always say control the controllables no
massive believer in that but I wasn't
doing that at all
mmm sauce old to me is you'd have your
own business within this Robertson
somewhat bubble but I was kind of I was
I was caught up in a whole of whole sort
of everything is going on around you and
not seeing not seeing the good stuff and
I was really I was acting like a
recruiter no I was acting what I
perceived a recruiter to act like which
wasn't me and I think what I learned was
you act like a you act like a
traditional recruiter you get treated
like a traditional recruiter okay most
people stereotype a recruiter as again
the exploitation pretty low so I think I
was going into it not I wasn't your mind
I wasn't I wasn't that's interesting I
don't think so I was I was just trying
to get some board what did you what was
you just straight on the light from a
source candidates would you straight be
then we we shot Sharon our business it's
quite a collaborative work force so or
sort of team at the time there was only
there was only seven of us oh wow so
it's quite small
yeah I joined a business of that science
a small team size working so you like
working over people's jobs maybe working
other people's roles to start with and
just trying to I was trying to sell to
people I was trying to sort of really
really go in and just just be this
flurry of energy and I've got I've got a
lot of energy but I wasn't sort of
seeing it for the right reasons or being
I don't think I was being Ramey that's
really that was quite a house okay so
how did you realize that then I realized
it cuz I just wasn't enjoying it I was
getting caught up with all this other
other staff and I was convinced I'd be a
good recruiter yeah again I was seen the
negatives rather than the positive yeah
and one massive positive they were quite
the team weren't that successful it was
very much Mark and his Merry Men
so mark was and still is a tremendous
that recruiter and at the time he was
probably billing
for 500k on his own and no joke but just
sort of him and a group of other people
kind of thing and I was kind of far
focusing on the other people where's
what I should have done was seen
everything that mark was doing US
interests brilliantly and try and adapt
it in my own my own way mum very like a
very Scelzi person I wouldn't say I'm
that salesy but I just soaked in as much
as I could from him so how did it sir
okay so how did you start doing that
just just he was in the office so he was
he was he was on the floor so I just
kind of listened into it to his calls I
was always gonna work harder than
everyone else at a hospital I've always
been up at 5:00 and will go to bed at
whatever time and just I was in the
operating it was all I was gonna I was
gonna do more activity than anyone so
that was that was one thing mmm I could
I can guarantee but I was again I wasn't
I wasn't very genuine I kind of changed
my mindset and looked at that everything
that mark was doing and I think if I
think is how I'd want to be treated as a
as a candidate rather than how I think I
should be as a recruiter I know that
sounds that kind of sounds a bit weird
by treating every candidate as if they
were my missus or my friend or whatever
and I try and do the best thing by just
do the right thing yeah do the right
thing and sort of let money not be my
momentum main motivator and that really
works mmm wonders for me I saw what then
happened to the end of that first year
then like did so fingers to fing starts
chasing I was I was reasonably I was
reasonably said I probably build maybe
30k within that first four months so no
not particularly
madam you know how much I'll build my
first 24 K mate oh yeah that being said
I think a lot of the best recruiters I
know didn't build that much in the first
year I find those maybe I made me feel
about
[Laughter]
because I think there's the process like
you've got invest in like relationships
to invest in doing the right thing and
not in the end then surprisingly the
money takes care itself right things
come from that I used a stupid analogy
but I used to work in Starbucks and
Starbucks is values were there's six
guiding principles right and they the
money and their shareholders came last
so their philosophy was we create a
great product great service great
working environment the rest will follow
and I kind of put that into recruitment
so I just tried to do the best by every
every candidate that I spoke to so be
make sure I come off every call being
everyone's favorite recruiter and
actually follow up with people what
recruiters do terribly especially that
first day you know just focus on
candidates they don't actually follow up
all okay mmm they speak to a candidate
they're not right for the job they're
looking at they just sort of fade into
the abyss yeah I didn't think that way
so I started building relationship with
candidates and guess what then they
started referring me into businesses and
it just it just snowballed that's really
interesting so okay cool so then those
seven months like what what would you
say then just to wrap that up like the
core of where you start to do
differently then was it was it this
simple mind shift of well actually less
than two stop treating everyone like a
number and just trying to just sell my
opportunity to every single person even
if it may not be right and just actually
do the right thing listen learn from
mark all these types of things and just
soak up things around so cup soaked up
just soak up everything and adapt
everything the way like I I wanted to
work ya know all I think about
see ya the office I recruited in yet
there's like eight people are sat next
to the owner of the business yeah and
like it's just an open plan office and
like you can listen you can hear every
single person on the phone everyone
around me had been doing it for two
three four five plus years so like yeah
if you're listening right now and you're
in that type of environment it's like
like stop thinking like you know how to
do it and start just being a sponge and
listen take feedback and all these
things there's a hundred percent look at
all the positives around you look at
look what people are doing where
it's hard to when you're in that because
like this it's easy to say isn't it like
stop looking at the negatives but like
it's hard when you're in that Oh 100%
and recruitment on the under ninety days
is the worst job because I how did you
get above that because it's hard to
because it ultimately that takes a bit
of sort of self-awareness and for you to
be able to go will actually come in like
just stop being an AA bed here and like
I just notice it change pretty quickly
really I noticed half the conversations
I was having I wasn't doing probably for
my best interest I was just doing to
build a relationship with someone mm-hmm
and I think if you start doing that
because the bit you worry about right is
that it's the business development and
actually picking up the phone and yeah
and making all these cold calls what you
realize is if you start being the best
recruiter into every single candidate
candidates don't they do care obviously
if you place them I'm not I'm not saying
that and that's obviously the goal mmm
but they it's also a service game like
cause if you're there go to recruitment
consultant and yet someone else just got
lucky by specking in their CV they'll
still come to you and they'll recommend
you to the the company they join mmm
yeah and AJ just started changing pretty
quickly so the first sort of three
months I I kind of just struggled a bit
to pick up to earn and then the next the
next couple I actually started seeing
some real success and then led into
actually a fairly decent start to my
first full year would you build me one
to eight so not a lot yeah but first
year that's not [ __ ] about it so last
year was pretty well it was it was okay
yeah we just never from when you where
you was right about that from it so okay
then to wrap that up then a lot of
people I think it's fair to say right
those first three months could have quit
right yeah definitely why didn't you
quit because because I I needed to prove
to myself I could I could do it and I
sort of I I wouldn't I wouldn't have
quit I was sort of thinking though that
time just get to the first yeah to
church I mean it was a good milestone
yeah it wasn't like a it wasn't like I
was gonna do this forever but it was I
guess E&C right yeah I needed to shake
myself and how my recruitment craze god
of every months that's gone by I've
loved the job more and more that's
amazing I think even still probably
two years in or maybe maybe not about a
year and a half in I wasn't sure I was
it was it was the perfect or as a
long-term thing but suddenly it just
starts clicking I know I know that
sounds I know that sounds crazy but if
you just constantly invest in the right
activity and constantly feel like you're
doing the right thing or feel
comfortable with everything you're doing
but also it is an activity game right
you need to speak to as many people as
you need to have the conversations you
do the right thing but it just kind of
clicks and you get so much so much back
from it and guess what you start working
with clients who actually want to want
to work we actually get on with mm-hmm
and you've got some sort of common
common ground with those people okay so
second ear them how old did that live
then because I feel like quite a lot Oh
quite a lot must have gone on for you to
them at the end of that year or
beginnings of the third year to then you
be in a position where you're managing
the whole team's you know I mean so how
did it so when did you become a senior
so I became a senior probably just just
after a year mark and did you want that
it was just a milestone it's kind of
like what you hear and what said that
meant what you then manage people
although I just meant you became a
senior and you go okay fair this is just
a LinkedIn change we started mark style
actually wanting to grow the business
I'm excited start seeing people how many
people were you at then still probably
about seven okay and because I had a
good relationship remark I sort of
sponged off of mark off from him I
started getting involved in the
recruitment process or he's just sitting
in and to use it wasn't like me making
the big decision or whatever and he I
was the first real sort of graduate that
he he'd hired with very little
experience most people who come from
sort of a sales background almost people
who had or certainly someone that yeah
success from so he wanted to duplicate
that and bring in a few more people like
that or loads of columns yeah probably
better than me
so I started saying on the sort of
getting involved in that type of stuff
and it just sort of naturally evolved
into that and I was doing I was doing
the job in the right way very like mark
mmm and I think we just we've got the
same exact same philosophy of how to to
do the role when I was quite mark hate
managing people right so yeah he's a
very good recruiter he's a terrible
terrible manager luckily and he manages
me now but that's what he was that's
what he was sort of bad at he was very
good and I was good at asking for
responsibility so I just kept saying to
me if I build this will you give me X
pay rises yeah and I just you managed up
right yeah so I just I kept knocking on
his door and saying can you put
something together and actually the
majority of the time I'd put something
together so I try and I try and go with
a solution of saying there's nothing in
place here right but if I build 30k in
the next two months will you give me
this give me some sort of team
leadership what can i mentor someone or
because that's just what I was really
interested management sort of background
in hospitality and I was seeing these
people coming in and I was actually
understanding that I hated the first
three months mmm
but then turned it round and I could
probably add so you has a story to solve
exactly I was starting to see what
seeing some real success at that point
so I sort of wanted to believe in
yourself for them exactly and I wanted
other people to see that I think I work
what I love about that is like you
really I you like you really identified
like your value yeah I mean besides then
yeah I think that that's obviously the
difference between people that
ultimately like but kind of another
Callum who'd done the same thing could
just continue on just billing making
more money but you recognized an
opportunity where you marks a great
biller built this business but he isn't
great at managing people and you saw
that actually I can actually add a lot
of value here yeah that's really
interesting and there was no real
support around anyone so everyone could
look at mark and think okay he's great
yeah but there was no practicality as
there was anyone putting their arm
around their shoulder and saying hey
he's doing something this is this is
this is what I do yeah
judge are we inside yeah that's what
that's nice really interesting so I
think I think that's what for me
personally I'd love to get your thoughts
on this but that's what I really like
around a smaller business yeah
definitely
Janome are definitely like for me I mean
moaning experiences I work for a big
insurance company and work for a small
insurance brokers and work for a creamy
business of a people and then work for a
start-up which again had that sort of
size people and then now start my own
business but if I my personal opinion is
if I would probably choose a smaller
business like you've experienced
probably a lot of the times because I
think unique opportunities like that can
present them said Oh hundreds you know I
mean 100% and I a lot of it was timing
mmm definitely but also the
proactiveness and you recognize an
opportunity because what's your wish
like when like people listening one that
might be in a big corporate whatever I
was sure that view on sort of bigger
haze page whatever to broker some
someone for example how do you what's
your sort of perspective on that I think
I think we'd give all I can Robert
Sumner or a smaller business would give
someone if you've got the initiative and
a real drive to to do the role and you
feel like you can create your own lane
and do the job the way you want to do it
I think your smaller businesses is
better in many ways and especially
Commission structure and having the
freedom to to probably do things the way
you want to do it there's no tape etc I
also think there's huge value in the in
the present cons of birth are one of our
biggest pillars actually our biggest
pillar at the moment Erin came from
Michael Page background only was there
eight months he's a trainer what I
always say it's like the training and
all the processes and all that that you
get exposed to it is exactly top-class
and and I think probably and those sort
of businesses you you could potentially
be not forced to do the way they they do
it but there's a bit more of like a this
is this is the page way yeah I don't
know I've never experienced the AIII
sort of interest them I take a bit of a
step back and let people kind of decide
their own way asked lots of questions as
to to what way someone wants to
their sort of ethos obviously there's a
Robertson sumner ethos in a way that is
interesting so okay so then when did it
so did you manage like a smaller group
of people before we managed whole team
yeah and that and that was definitely
been the hardest part of my so how many
people did you manage so I had a team of
four okay and that was after how long
that's two years mark right let's do it
like did you do some mentorship before
did you go straight from I did I did I
did a little bit mentorship and kind of
guided guided people through that first
couple of weeks or at least gave
training sessions yeah cetera it was
nothing like it was kind of just a
switch of one day right Callum is now
senior consultant / team leader or
building manager or whatever you want to
call it and you still have to build that
point so I had to be at that point yeah
really and then how long do you do that
for I did that probably only for about
six months and that was quite time and
that was really tough and that's when I
first that time management was something
that why was that so tough then so you
went straight to time management was it
well just time management was always
something I just saw people put on their
CV or some like a filler I mean like I'm
a team player I work hard and I've got
great time management skills but that
that then you could actually see the
value because everything before that I
was quite an introvert in my own desk if
you know I mean like you have your own
process it was my 100% my own destiny so
whatever I put in I knew I was I was
gonna get no and I didn't really need to
to speak to to too many other people I
loved using all my energy to go out to
candidates and clients and speak to them
but the team leader so I kind of just I
probably went too much the other way and
too much the managerial way and actually
saw the role changing changing into like
a management role so it started trying
to offer my advice where actually maybe
I didn't need to if you know I mean I
actually saw the role change for us in
hindsight I would have I probably I
probably wouldn't have done that I would
let people come to come to me if they've
got questions okay so well you're
somewhat you mean by that is you said
instead
of imposing how come how you want people
to do it yeah we mean yeah so I was
probably to sort of fall fright and
wanting to sort of have one two ones and
and it'll catch up swear as to be honest
that should have just led led from the
front as I was because I kind of became
crap at both you know I mean my billing
has actually suffered but also I wasn't
the best team leader because I was kind
of half-assed was that because what use
them worried about your Billings yeah it
kind of so I was I then went back to
effectively what I was like at the start
I was like a fifty percent focused on
recruitment yes and fifty percent and I
would you go do that though honey
I was never Billy manager though so but
my opinion is you're always best a
hundred percent focused on one thing
okay so that's why time management
became really important to me so I
actually sort of since then I've died of
my days into eight so I know I'm gonna
be in the office at least from eight
till six or I'm gonna be around if no I
have our meetings or whatever I can sort
of assigned time to do that so I blocked
blocked it into eight and just put three
sessions as to when I was there to help
and actually people don't need help all
the time people don't need management or
someone telling them what's new it's a
it's a very sort of self learning yeah
type job what what they need is and if
you give people like stabilizers or you
give people something they'll just use
it all the time so then they start
asking for my advice or can you can you
tell me how to get in with this company
or can you give me an in here or
whatever that's not what people need to
develop they need to sort of be left on
their own they need to be able to fish
themselves as it were rather than sort
of just giving them giving them a fish
so will you send they're the bigger so a
few things they're just just to make
sure it's clear I think that's a really
interesting point right so just unpack
that you said you realized and
recognized the why are you is still
trying to impose the kalam wag probably
a bit too much for trying to influence
how they did it as opposed to them sort
of learning themselves and these lots of
things and then also you was getting
pulled pillar to post and which men that
we didn't have much organization didn't
have time management and you became not
so great billing and not so great and
managing right yeah so to solve that you
obviously recognize that and then so
then how do you actually structure a day
so what would you would you explain that
just to make it so I I see made chance
of your diary chunks of my diary so for
for Chung eight or twelve for four hours
and then and say and basically what that
chunks there is Hisham your Myrick Rio
so between between eleven if you've got
any questions about that's the time that
you ask men come on come to me I'll give
you I'll give you twenty minutes I'll
give you five minutes I'll give you an
hour how long but there's the window
there's a training session if it's just
got this problem what would you do do
that mmm because ninety percent of time
people solve their own problems yeah how
does it help then how did that help how
did that solve the point is that
actually allowed me to focus on my own
billings whenever whenever I wasn't in
one of those hour chunks and then
focused purely on management in those so
what you're saying they allow you to be
President exactly yes so whenever I was
having conversation with someone who
thought I was a hundred percent mmm but
can't Candice and clients in recruiting
time and then mmm consultants in in
management time yeah however you want to
look at it yes I think that's so
important everyone's everyone's got
stuff that happens I hope everyone's got
stuff that gets in there in their mind
but the the best the best billows of
people who are a hundred percent focused
on the task the task at hand
yeah and not focusing on the 101 now
Athena I think that's a really good in
that's a really good insight and so
really good practical advice there for
people that I hope for they can
implement so was out pretty the biggest
realization or definitely and that was
something that I kind of I've done I did
management before and I kind of assumed
I was gonna be good at that but how did
you get to that time management solution
was in reading books was it off your own
sort of just intuition just by because a
lot of the questions people were asking
me work stuff that to be honest a could
wait yeah and and be I just like it
wasn't it didn't make sense to me to
answer it asked and as you say I was
half present I was kind of I was kind of
giving them an answer which was kind of
bollocks anyway yes I just wanted to get
them off my back yeah that's so true I
had a call or I was really focused on
something else and that
that wasn't working for anyone that
wasn't helping any know anyone else grow
and it wasn't helping my my Billings in
the slightest either so it wasn't it was
kind of just self self-learning and
actually just doing it okay so then
after those six months then you then
managed that was a really really really
big step did you ask her at those I did
yeah saying it mark was just we were
growing to a point so I joined when we
had seven consult since that point we
probably had about twelve and it's a
tough number I'll run that and that it's
a toss to like get past it was a tough
number mark was getting ridiculously
stressed with with all of the with all
the management side he really didn't
want to do it he wasn't necessarily that
good at it he was a much better bitter
than me and we were at a point where I
was probably I was building around 15k a
month plus having no [ __ ] bad no it's
not terrible but it's enough for someone
like Mark to be able to cover mine my
desk and yeah real short-term and think
right I can take this hit now but at
that point I was 20 24 and then for a 24
year old to look after a business and
specially someone's pride and joy mm-hmm
it marks so when he said look after the
business what you mean was another just
managing the people just just take over
take over the team take over every
decision that wasn't recruitment really
yeah we we had we have an ops type chap
who looks after that the invoicing and
yeah it wasn't that stuff but just to
make that clear so then from that point
and you managed work exactly so you must
everybody merged twelve twelve twelve
consultants yeah any decision that
wasn't recruitment base so what we were
gonna put our marketing budget on and so
that I puff okay and then also internal
hiring internal wiring yeah okay so just
everything and then you've been in that
ever since you know ever since yeah than
that yeah again I think this is such a
cool story to share with people that if
you're in a sort of small ground
business right now there's life you want
it as opportunities to be Hance once
you've proven your you've got a basic
level of experience in recruitment and
you can actually build something and you
can
something from nothing I'm a massive
believer it's all on ya honey and I
think what you've sort of explained this
stuff it's something that I think so
like my old recruitment and Matt so hit
the the chat that I owned the business
light I think what you're talking about
there is really interesting as well
because I I think personally if I looked
around the room in there my old office
there's some people that just turn up
that size business and just do their
thing
yeah which is fine and you need those
people but I think you you're a bit
similar to me where what what you've
done really well is like obviously
you've done everything you need to in
terms of to show mark that you're
someone that he can trust in these
things but you've really built a unique
relationship with mark you know I mean
yeah and that's also something that
people can do and I've sort of quite
naturally done that like he's still a
mentor to me now and I can only speak
some of these things but if it's like if
you were to look around that office then
like how many people were trying to
really cultivate that relationship to a
point where it's like well actually
there's a really opportunities for me
you know I mean yes really implies you
can actively do that if you want it 100
percent but people put in this imagine
you like glass ceiling of you can't do
it but no-one else has done it
mmm which to me just didn't make sense
yeah like if I asked the responsibility
if Mark doesn't want to do something if
he doesn't wanna manage people mmm
there's gonna be a solution that's gonna
have to be a solution at some point in
the road like if he wants to grow the
business no qualifying out with him does
he actually want to grow their business
yes I really like I really go with this
solution don't go with a problem and I
don't just add to his problems you know
manage right so you don't wanna manage
give me a timescale give me what you
want me to do in order to take that take
that man off you actually borrowed last
question so how many people do you have
there now 20 21 Wow so that must have
been quite interesting yeah so that
there the first year of me looking after
things and it was it was hard for mark I
think I think probably in hindsight for
him is probably the best decision he's
ever made but also one of the worst no
it owned only in the sense of it was his
baby like and everything kind of
revolved around him
whereas now he's kind of not obsolete
because he's still very very much takes
part but he doesn't need to be there
which is quite difficult I think for us
I mean no she said what lights we can go
and for what 16 years 19 years 19 years
to light obviously he'd be like it wakes
up every day knows what he needs to do
now he's like I've got this [ __ ] 24
year old running short on the football
if I do a hundred percent and that I
think was really fast no this was
personal challenges yeah exactly I think
what you realize is because it was with
him in the room you put a ceiling
yooper ceiling there because he he
manages his own teas billing and people
don't realize what they can do whereas
we had some really good talent and then
suddenly guess what everyone starts
building a lot more Wow marking his
Merry Men everyone's kind kind of got
their own little business and their own
little interesting way of way of doing
things and people just start growing
people and it just sort of booms that
first year we grew 59 percent really and
we soared you put that down to what I
put that unto to mark mark taking less
responsibility and giving people more so
one one person it's kind of like how
this is analogy how do you eat an
elephant like not just loads of people
taking small chunks so it was kind of it
was kind of like that mmm it's taking
taking everything off of one person and
giving loads of people more
responsibility and when like myself when
given more responsibility people step up
to the register step up to the mark and
people start billing more people start
thinking okay this is this is serious
now and start earning proper proper
money and I can start developing my own
relationships and this is this is my own
recruitment business within this Robert
Sumner bubble rather than I'm kind of
one of marks hmm yeah definitely I think
that especially in especially in that
site light sort of close environment
that must have been intense that people
felt like that too then that must have
been some sort of an interesting relief
for people do you not I mean to feel
like this couch apps is running shop now
and like it's just 20 for a kid night
why do you have to manage people older
than you yeah
and as our difficult
not particularly because the other thing
a that's too much too much of an issue I
think people have seen I was very ver
sort of respectful when I'm on the the I
I'm just not coming across of Leon oo
I'm 24 that's when there's trouble and
I'm a massive mindset that he does need
sort leaders eat last and it's like my
responsibility if anything the higher I
go the less mmm the less kind of less
it's about you perks and stuff I I get
it's all about it's all about them mmm
it's just giving them the platform to
yeah to grow and actually once you start
start seeing that so then they had a
success story that wasn't marked some of
the business they had they had another
success story and you just branch off
more and more people people like that
and then and then it makes it easier
hiring for yourself because you can say
Oh errands on this or Adams done this or
just like me exactly I've actually
people being successful okay so what was
okay cool so then over the over the over
the last three years then for you then
there's now managing this business it's
been focusing on growing the business
yeah no any headcount but in terms of
revenue in these things so how we done
on that standpoint we've we've just so
we've grown we started we started with
bat 12 when I first took the position
and now we're at 21 very 59 percent 30
34 percent and we've already hit our
number this year I suppose in terms of
revenue so things are amazing okay so
let look what I'd be keen to get your
force on now because I think you're in a
not always love talking about this
because I think it can sort of give you
the opportunity to give some real value
to people listening and through that
whole journey their mate how obvious Lee
you've been seeing these people flutter
flourishing and getting more
responsibilities etc etc etc besides
obviously the the unique nuance or
Robertson Sumner in that top environment
what have been the sort of core things
that you picked up on notice that your
guys girls now who are flying top
performers whatever have you seen them
grow and see the things that they've
changed and the habits that they've
implemented they're there what are some
of the key things that you picked up on
some
it's kind of having the mindset to do it
I know that sounds silly but I'm a
massive believer that you should reflect
every day even every week and every
month and every because you just you
don't know how far you've come unless
you take the time unless you do that and
I can't I kind of encourage people to
break down their days like I did when I
go into sort of eight and make sure to
of those eight chunks is trying
something new and actually working on
the end of the day did that work was
that good was that bad and then I was
really impressed either cutting it down
or doubling up on that because some
things work for people some things
people hate like so when you say sorry
just the button there when you say
caught view then eh what do you mean so
again four four four slots between eight
and eight and twelve four slots between
two and two and six I okay okay but if
it's a say if it's for its for okay I
find I lose I've got a really sick short
attention span so no no I agree I've
done I've done me I've done it myself
recently definitely in terms of a lot
blocking out certain chunks to do just
that and these things so but that's
really interesting okay so mindset and a
part of how these people how they how
that's become better for people is
you've encouraged them to try different
things you've encouraged them to reflect
these types of things and also just
someone's got to have a big why they've
got they've got actually understand why
they're why they're doing it and why
Robert Sumner ER are doing it and if I'm
not a believer that should be money I
know people say oh they draw diagrams of
Ferraris and Porsches and yeah and
Rolexes or whatever that may be and they
they sort of draw out chunks it's the
closer they get that will work for some
people right but there's got to be
something beyond that I think what mine
is stupid but it reflects everything I
do I've my sort of wise I want to do a
TED talk so really yeah so so stop top
line I said to CV or what and it has
been since I started so when I do a TED
talk and I want to make two people
millionaires really and what's so cool
and what that well that says about me
it's not just I want to earn four
hundred thousand pounds next year away
well that says about me or what what I
believe is I want to do something that's
changes the world
that's so cool I want to impact
something and I can reflect back on that
every day right cut them out there eight
chunks that you've done out the two
things you've tried have you done
anything that was in an innovative
enough to change the world or to make to
move forward as that task of being doing
a TED talk
so may I love that but why does that
help me as a recruiter why is that
because because you can you've got
something that's that's they're
constantly pushing you forward but for
example Aaron in the team is you say and
it's crazy as soon as someone starts
doing stuff everyone starts doing stuffs
okay I never thought anyone would bill
and we're we're outside the city but I
never thought Aaron 2023 and build 165 K
in the last six months well but he's
only done it to become top of the
leaderboard so now he's top of the
leaderboard he's like what the [ __ ]
so he needs to have something else to
push him forward because otherwise you
get stopped a leaderboard I've done my I
think that lasted the whole like money
thing and all that is like all right so
when I get a Rolex or whatever and you
get there it's like it's not that great
I always remember it like again outside
the London but I remember again like my
biggest paycheck in recruitment Oh golly
I remember just sitting it in my bank
and on like it didn't make me feel
anything do you know I mean that is some
mad feeling cause like I just always had
that my headlight
yeah keep pushing this is what I wanna
do blow money money money and then like
you get like the biggest amount of
you've ever had in your career in this
light just don't yes mad so how is that
gonna help me push free then you know I
mean because some people might be
listening guy yeah I'll get there like
why so common but obviously a lot of
people may think it's just bit wanky
like how how is that how is that how
Aaron gets at that point you know I mean
how has it helped him become the top guy
I think it had a strong it's just again
you could you could only look at
yourself in recruitment you don't know
no one will stop you from being
successful so there's got to be some
sort of extraneous variable that
makes you that takes you there in in in
my mind like as I said once you've got
the personality to do the to do the job
you're you're a nice fellow you've you
or guy or gal or or whatever there's got
to in my mind there's got to be
something further that drives you that
drives you forward because otherwise
you'll get people and again it changes
for different people yeah recruiters I
know have that know I agree I agree
definitely so guess just a final point
on that again I think and uh people
listening like if I'm a manager right
now and I've got three people around me
all got free calendars running around
and I just think like they are they are
struggling like they're letting the bad
days get the better than these things
and already think okay Callum what is
sin having that sort of bigger picture
thinking why they're doing that these
types of things gonna help them get
through that right so how have you how
have you got that in your people do you
not I mean cuz that must that can't
always be easy I find I've learned
especially managing is to take a step
back always always ask questions don't
necessarily answer questions so if
someone comes the problem they'll answer
the question themselves you've just got
to pose the right the right question I
think I think you you learn that not
everyone's not everyone's in an era not
everyone wants to build ridiculous
amounts of money and a business is
successful if you've got twenty twenty
consultants all doing 150 K you'll be
fine now you'll be successful so I think
it's looking at everyone as individuals
and that trust him and that why doesn't
have to be that why doesn't have to be
owning a ten million pound house yeah
that could just be I want to create a
comfortable life for my family and I
want to be able to buy every Friday and
super would you directly ask his people
to think about it other recent 100% and
I'd keep going back to it really I keep
going back to it right you said you how
early on you get in to think about that
though first time really yeah there's
got to be something I and it allows me
to know more about you because I want to
know what is actually pushing you
because if I say oh you haven't done you
think in 10 K this this month or
whatever bit did you really do you
really want that Rolex or do you do
yeah you do come on yeah yeah actually
because I'm with you I bought a suti
when our boy will watch my first
paycheck but that the money in my bank
didn't mean to me no nothing Aaron
billing to whatever K it means something
obviously can he live certain lifestyle
but because of it all you you can you
can know that lifestyle but half of the
fun for him is getting to the top of the
leaderboard like yes it's not the money
it's the it's the thing behind the money
yeah I mean so I think it's important
that you understand that I think it's
important you understand what someone
actually wants to achieve and keep
pushing them in the same because if you
manage everyone the same everyone will
just don't know yeah that's nice really
interesting okay and what how cause I've
sort of seen it myself and how how have
you found or what what what do you think
has been the core of the success of you
going from 12 to 20 21 people do you
think having having other people
delivering and sort of success stories
and and a vibe around that we've got
such a much better engaged workforce and
honestly anyone would do anything for
anyone and he's developing that
developing that culture I think it's
quite hard just to be a lone wolf I
think at the start of my recruitment
career that was what I actually
struggled struggled with because
everyone was kind of a lone wolf looking
at mark thinking no one will ever do
that is now it's funny is that sort of
4-minute mile type time lovest once
someone does something they pushes the
next person to do it and then it pushes
the next person to do it and then once
once you've once you've started pushing
people once you've got these success
stories and I think it's quite easy to
do boring new people in and actually
think okay these guys being successful I
need to copy what were the two core
things you look in for highs for your
business humility I think every every
recruiter every recruit I've or
successful recruit I was actually proud
of being a recruiter and they they don't
know
themselves into two sort of high regard
and they don't think they're the the
dog's bollocks yeah
and probably the mindset because to to
humility and probably mindset and
reflection and growing yeah yeah and all
that good stuff that they're the
personality has got to be there I'm not
a big believer that anyone can be a
million-pound biller or whatever you
still got to have the right personality
or you put Harry Kane next to me I can't
be that I'm just not I'm hobbling around
on crutches
[Laughter]
you've got haven't ya I know I like that
yeah so how do you how do you pick up on
humility in an interview and the mindset
because how do you try and find that out
and so quite interesting because I
actually went for a time where there was
a point where we were struggling for
vacancy so we were struggling for like a
conveyor belt of vacancies and I went
against my ethos and start hiring more
salesy people people I thought well
we're Scelzi yeah they're a bit more
arrogant
mmm I didn't actually like them as much
really and I think that's important
because I think not only will I cells is
kind of a popularity contest right
though you've got to get on with the
person next year yeah if I if I like you
I'd do as much as I could to to help you
and I think that's exactly the same on a
sales floor or a crewman crewmen floor
and I think part part is just wood do
you like sand when are they are they I
don't like people that boast too much
especially when they they don't have
anything to to boast around I want
someone who's got a bit of a why who
really wants to do it and you can coach
you can coach someone who you want to
have a conversation to be successful
what was what's difficult is because we
started hiring these people who we
thought when they didn't work out they
just traditional they'd act like a
recruiter but then they get treated like
her it wasn't it wasn't business
development yeah you should mention it
they're always like talking about is
probably one of them I always found him
a very common topic that people want me
to cover
and also we were also we're catching up
earlier but I guess two things I'd love
to get your thoughts on business
development for your team and these
types of things
how are the the good people the good
guys and gals approaching business
development in your team or have they
got better at it my personal approach
visit development if I was short of
rolls you see me sort of registering and
interviewing more candidates like I'd
always go back to the candidate get as
much sort of and just just build as good
a relationship as I can because they're
they're the best in like especially in
sales mmm sanika specking in candidates
it's just getting information from
they're not my goal again was to to kind
of just get people jobs so if I've got a
good relationship with the candidate now
that will get me into then they'll get
me into the account and they'll give me
the the guys or girls mobile number to
call it cetera so like a genuine
genuinely we use a lot of video now so
so videos videos great and actually
having a reason behind it and trying to
add more value so what are you always
used to do in a business development
type sense was again I'd keep close to
all my candidates whether I replace them
or not I'd still send that candidate
something when they started so if I
found out that you started a new role
but I didn't place you but you still
really like me and I was the best
recruitment result and you spoken to I'd
send you a gift and I notice if I send
it to your to your nice gonna send it to
your manager yeah I'd say your manager
Paul aware of hey Paul understand you've
had hm
great hire by the way really really
liked him and I try and add some more
value so just so you know I got this
psychometric test or I got his p60
here's who he says he is by the way and
kind of like a soft soft sell of this is
who I am are speaking I speak and teach
and before you I would love to and just
loads of loads of little threads like
that and it came out so adding as much
value as you can outside of the
recruitment space not just talking about
jobs I don't know yeah just know that's
that's a really good point yeah sorry
about that
the may like this lights and the hunting
officers I don't know let's come up with
solution
no I really like the way that you put
that and really interesting again it's
coming back to sort of your mindset
towards recruitment and stuff isn't it
the fact that you're willing to recruit
is listening like why the hell would you
send a gift to someone who didn't place
like why the hell would I do that right
but you're thinking long term you're
thinking that's the type of recruit
either how I want to be perceived in
these types of things right and then the
other thing that I'd love to get your
and thoughts on mate because we're
talking about earlier like you were
saying before before we came on here
that you've been like you've been
pulling jobs right yeah the most
probably love fed say yeah how you been
doing that let's talk a bit about that I
mean did that I think when you lose your
your quota there's a bit of a weird one
when you lose your quota you start
becoming less keen to I think it's like
when you take it I put always
recruitment as like a dating analogy
once you start becoming desperate to
find missus or another half or whatever
it's really hard people know you're
desperate so when you're coming across
when you're pretty chilled about it when
you're just doing something for the best
of best of every party I I think it just
becomes really easy I get I've got much
more content out I'm a lot more video
out but none of its really related to
recruit minutes or you selling exactly
people use LinkedIn celebrate success so
I'll celebrate with them I'll find it
and I'll always have a reason to call I
never make a local I never make a
business of Emmental without a def
definitely not definitely not but once I
did once I've got Fred going
I'd be structured with that or a lot of
people have poor out recruiting they
they do the perfect thing they've got a
recent school they've got a strong
reason to call they get through to the
person the person probably says I'm not
recruiting firm two months or whatever
right grant we call back in two months
and then they forget about it they lose
it my diary was always full when I was
recruiting of course
yeah I'd always I always put them in and
make sure people knew I was going to
call okay and if they if they if they
didn't then it just makes the whole
process a shows the or actually delusion
and you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna follow
thus what your ethos is what we making
content about while making content about
it's quite it's probably easier for me
because I'm making a lot of contact make
a lot of content about our business and
that how are you yeah you do that cover
success success story but how is that
pulling jobs how's that putting jobs
because it gets it gets loads of people
engaging if you if you've got a few
power post and you've got 180 people
like it or talking about it or whatever
it only gives the consultant the
opportunity to say hey I saw you people
love just like in stuff and lamenting on
people doing well especially piano you
have this you the you've you've done
quite well in celebrating people's
success in your business celebrating
people's success just getting content or
out around sort of best best practices
when it when it comes to recruitment and
not necessarily talking about I think
you've got a lot more value in this
market I think rather than just talking
about talking about jobs all the time I
think there's actually got to be a lot
of added value and I probably turn away
at least 50% of the roles that I'd get
because I think it's impossible and I'd
always tell people it's impossible and I
actually quite enjoy both Canada and
client side because what can that's
always going to say is the same dating
dating analogy yeah he said I want you
to find me a new role can you find me
Margot Robbie or Angelina Jolie or
whatever I just say that's you're not
[Music]
saying no been on this yeah you've got
to be realistic but I'd make a bit of a
joke out of it right tell you why never
you never bloody find that but what I'll
do I'll give you a call back in two
weeks and you can you can try and prove
me I'm wrong because if they if they do
if they somehow miraculously get and in
this this and instance Margot Robbie's
been Google and Angie and Jodi's
Microsoft if they do that by then by a
couple of days yeah a nice you'll get in
with those you'll get with those
companies and exactly the same with
clients because otherwise I like it may
cover things before we finish yeah and
what's been your biggest learning since
been on this sort of management journey
learning that people won't care about
the business as much as I care about the
diverse interesting I get really really
frustrated all the time because I'm so
passionate about it I love the business
to death and and so on so are other
people but it's it's my it's my baby
it's not there
they're not gonna care as much as you
can't you can't think that they're gonna
differ from the you exactly so it's
unrealistic and I think it's unrealistic
and I think it's unfair as well everyone
the same because there are some people
who were happy building 150k and earning
40 grand and in my head obviously at the
start I didn't understand that so that
was really difficult
that's really why didn't you want to
learn more what are you doing yeah just
just chill out get them night yeah
that's that's fine people aren't gonna
care as much as what I all I can do is
be there for the ones that do do you
want to do more and actually just push
people too so again is recognizing like
everyone's in their own land in their
own thing respect than that yeah 100%
it's not getting to four straight that
doesn't mean they can't be born to the
business it just means that they can't
be bought another kind of standard and
there's a big difference you can't say
everyone the same standards that you've
got yes otherwise people like that just
say nice pretty interesting ridiculously
ridiculously high standards with with
everything hmm and if I did that with
other people it would only drive people
away like it doesn't it doesn't make
sense you've got to look at everyone as
a unique individual and set their own
standards and them set their standards
as well but just encourage them to do
more it courage them to be the best
person that they can they can be a lot
of that then try and make them into a
calendar because that doesn't make sense
yeah I really like that so two things
just because I've got I've had a couple
of messages about recently so I wanted
to make sure I'd definitely ask that and
I'm sure your guys deal with this anyway
so I'd be interested to get your
thoughts counteroffers okay counter
what's life if you're if your guys come
to you you're one of your girls come to
you and goes Callum blump I'm not sure
like this person said they're gonna
accept a counteroffer or I think it
might be prone to or whatever like that
top of a counter offers what sure yeah
what's just sort of go-to advice to your
guys welcome to my a make sure you
qualify out in the closing in the
closing process people closing in
recruitment is one of those things
especially when you're new to
recruitment it seems really easy right
yeah it's gonna be yeah and you
celebrate straightaway yeah and you
don't ask the other questions you don't
even find out when you say
qualifier the clothes what do you mean
when you've given the offer or qualify
before the clothes when they say you say
yeah delight if they came back with 40k
on a trial clothes or whatever I
definitely I definitely accept so if
you've got counter-offered and they and
your current business offered you 50 K
what would you say what would you say to
that
I'd completely out of it I'm done right
perfect
that's at least qualify out whereas most
people just say well yeah you've got the
job under the table yeah where is he and
and you can't cut it out all the time
everyone knows that mmm 80% of people or
whatever who accept a counteroffer leave
within six months or whatever the status
but still and you can't control it all
the time especially in the sales market
people will people will lie although
don't just mmm they won't tell the truth
ourselves you but at least if you've
qualified out the sort of option of them
gain counteroffer you've got understand
that these guys you're going through the
recruitment process every day and these
guys it's a one-off they probably
haven't looked for a new job in a while
yeah they probably haven't even thought
about a counteroffer or if they have
yeah then you've probably prone to
something there so you're gonna have to
be safe so if I'm if I come to and said
Kalymnos got my sales guy who I
qualified out did that he told me to
accept it he's told me that he's he's
probably gonna accept the Cameron offer
he's been counting offered 10k more than
or for whatever and what's your advice
my advice there's probably not too much
yeah too much you can do unfortunately
you can educate the market as to the
stats the stats around it and you can
actually you should qualify out
obviously why the person's looking to
leave Nitin thanks percent of the time
people aren't looking for for money
there's a horse yeah Oh Steve other
variables as to why they've left it's
just making sure you've got all that
info there because it's hard to people
don't like their manager right your
manager is still there but they forced
you ten more okay yeah okay no it says I
know I like I think there's some good
stuff there like that because that's why
people who've asked me cuz they've
they've feel like it
has been happening more I think
especially there's never been such a
count like candidates short market so
whenever the candidates short market
obviously people are going to try just
because um yeah like might some my old
boss will catch something over Dana
saying economy needs that figure but I
think he pretty much said like 200 codes
were for business that had been like
counting off at the web and my it's like
the most it's ever been so it's
interesting you just said that and
picked up on that yeah it's difficult
but you've got to understand he was
drivers why they're looking to leave I
can't I think I read it somewhere or
listen to podcast or something but a
really good advice that I remembered
like really resonated with me and was
ask the questions you don't hear the
answer to like around that stage I think
that's just a really good thing to have
in mind it cuz I understand at the
beginning like you just want to hear
what you want to hear yes your than that
[ __ ] dealer to be close you know I
mean a couple of times yeah certain
learn that early on this light for me to
definitely be really confident and
putting this on the board or thinking
I'm putting on the board then walk up 10
super hot stop this from happening okay
mate last thing yeah
slightly different what's been the
weirdest or strangest or funniest thing
a candidate said to you two when not
attending them to be or to like not
didn't my favorite to be fair was
because this takes real effort right so
he probably like planted a seed the
night before saying I showed I don't
think he did but there was something
there's something around I was I was
calling him to prep him in the morning
yeah the interview was midday or
wherever so quit him at nine o'clock and
he changed his voicemail to say hi if
this is anyone at Roberts and Sumner
calling I have been rushed to hospital
and won't be able to make the interview
and that was his like I didn't even want
to pick up the phone premeditation he
woke up a a.m. that morning and thought
I'm gonna change my voice
that's joke that was a best joke that
was what you get horses don't you but
that's Jake's them that takes just tell
me you don't want to go right now learn
really enjoyed that were you excited
about mate what's gone on in there we're
gonna we're gonna move office so that's
pretty exciting so start of 2021 we're
sort of ramping up ramping up now with
we're gonna get a 40 man oh wow 40 man
office yes it's gonna be ping pong
tables people 10 beers yeah beanbag a
lot mayor like proper mate that's really
that's amazing though yeah obviously
like you must be London lies too good
for that whole journey and process you
know I mean I've gone through loads
we've rebranded in my in my time I've
sort of managed manage that take it
taking that taking that from the process
now we moved off this one so we only
upstairs so we moved from a mr. 2025 C
office that we're in now and we're
looking to move again it's it's time to
become Mosin oh really
Joe yeah you don't reflect on these
things yeah it started as last
excitement a little baby and now it's
it's really exciting so yeah the hiring
hiring lots looking to we're hiring a
mock we could just tied a marketing exec
so it's client on yeah
we're kids go solo last question if you
could communicate to every single
recruit right now you had listened their
take on an advice what do you say my
best bit of advice I think would be stop
stop worrying about money and start
worrying about learning every single day
and building relationships and not just
trying to not just try to put money on
the board from the first build build
relationships if you if you constantly
focused around building relationships
and learning and reflecting and growing
you'll be absolutely sure McCrimmon you
may not build a ridiculous amount first
year but if you keep putting the work in
keeping the hours in your you're
learning every day
the waltz the watch your wrist this this
so this so much there's no ceiling in
recruitment ready come enjoy them if
it's Frankie no